[Music]
hahaha once again I have stolen the game
from Yahoo - haha he will never know
it's in my plan to play a game at the
same time with him comes to fruition
okay I saw this game um well everyone
was recommending it to me and I saw the
yamimash did playing I checked out the
pre-release trailer and it looked like
really interesting it's supposed to be a
mix of slender and dead space I thought
it was just gonna be a simple thing but
this looks very complicated and there's
a two-player co-op which means that once
that comes out or it's not out yet once
it does come out maybe yamimash want to
play with me I don't know we'll find out
[Music]
oh no way this is awesome look at that
oh that doesn't look good table oom oh
that's bad
ah well that's not much of a flashlight
wow this is awesome
freaky what how did I do that
ah yeah I don't know I don't know how I
did that okay I just there's a delay on
the clicking to the Getty
Wow
yeah when you guys first were talking to
me about it I mean a lot of the Slender
games that are made by other people are
not that high quality but this this one
actually looks like it's gonna be pretty
nice I mean I really like it so far
this is like wicked awesome man I don't
know I'm looking for power nodes
apparently cuz got to throw that dead
space in there don't know why I would
need power nodes to upgrade my
non-existent gun and my non-existent rig
okay well whatever we're doing
I like it now I don't like it I like it
there's nothing in here I didn't think
there was anything in there I hope I
didn't miss something
click slay
it is what what what you doing what you
doing what you doing ha ha let's go down
ok so far so ok oh not the bathroom the
bathroom is always bad no matter what
horror game you're plagued the bathroom
is always bad let's go in the bathroom
ok it's the what ghosts gonna make a
reappearance oh is that a power node oh
I done bad
why would slender want anything to do
with dead face that seems like a
horrifying combination going go away
Slendy I don't want any oh by the way
this is made on the Unity engine I
usually you'd like to try to mention
that voice airplane come on Oh oh good
its people going marker crazy that's
always a good sign marker crazy slender
crazy got a similar I guess what it
seems
hmm stop it come back I can't see dick
it's like really dark and stuff
Oh powered out I mean even sleeps under
yet I like freaking out
Joey Joey Joey said I don't want any I
don't wanna play another bathroom touch
oh no oh this is a waste of time
he's gotta got me he's gonna nibble on
my giblets he's gonna jumble on my
niblets anyway my niblets and giblets
are going no no aah
fog fog
I've really liked the design of this
game I just do not lengthen he's not
showing up I've got two power nodes and
admittedly that's not very much I don't
I don't think wait wasn't I Oh No yeah I
was in the opposite side these kind
these things are kind of similarly built
it's like a mirrored ship I don't know
how big this place is it doesn't seem
like it has that much maybe I'm supposed
to try to open these lockers out of them
blood on the walls blood on the walls
why is our Bothell house I don't know I
don't want to know three of halfway to
destruction quarter life halfway halfway
to destruction okay the slender music
keeps getting louder and there's no
Slendy there's no Slendy Lemmy is not
here where is Sundy
this is where I first came in why was I
just standing in that little room Slendy
nose is getting like really loud ah go I
go I go where I can't run
there's no sprint you got to be [ __ ]
with me I didn't even see him I just saw
this tonic ah
wait maybe I didn't check like all of
this area all of the other this area I
didn't know what it looked like before
maybe there's not much else to go
we're gonna go it's like this ship is
not that big
this ship is not that bag where the hell
my father go open dammit hmm well Sam is
he down there I can't see him
oh come on already good where am I
supposed to go
dad really echo in here okay seriously
there's not that much ship to explore
I've already been in the bathroom maybe
there was like come on darn these doors
need work apart oh wait no this way okay
I got it there's more ship let's buy a
lot more ship I only need three more
power notes oh god there's so much ship
oh god oh god oh god okay let's just go
right right I can't see jack bunch of
beds I can't see diddly doodlee do it is
like coats mixed groats dark it is just
dark darkness you'd think in the future
with all the advanced technologies they
could make high powered flashlights I
mean in dead space power node basically
everything on Isaac Clark glowed gosh ha
good thing I wasn't looking that might
have startled me I don't even know what
that was is like some sort of weird body
creature kind of looks like one of the
monster from cry of fear but I do not
know okay so we're done here it's just
three more two more only two more Slendy
is not making that much of an appearance
and that's good what yeah nose in the
game yes cuz he don't trust you oh
that's awesome thank you so much I'm in
the game
who's this yeah I don't know that's
awesome I didn't know that nobody
mentioned that to me gosh
gerrae i love games of reference less
players
another do I jump down there no it's not
let's not jump down there and say we did
Dom in a game haha that's the second
time that's happened okay I'm really
curious odd damn it's so dark I'm really
curious as to why Slendy is not showing
up so much oh man it's so cool dr. Barr
I've never been called dr. markiplier I
guess from my surgeon simulator people
realize that I was just feeling sick
lying down dead like hahaha that's so
awesome okay thank you so much maker
they came I really do appreciate this
maybe that was why people were so
adamant to get me to play the game okay
so what's down here oh this looks good
morgue let's go there last sounds like a
plan
wow this looks very morgue like to me
what is this what is this this looks
like a Maurice I thought he said furnace
I guess is where they burn all the
bodies where I didn't see him give me a
damn power node I need two more this
ship is so damn big I thought it was
smaller but it's so damn big oh did I
just walk into the morgue I just walked
into the morgue tonight
oh okay I'm out of here
if I go back into the furnace through
this way what's that oh no wait that's
the back end of the back I gotta get to
them no who's that I don't know this is
yeah that's style that's where I came
from cuz I remember there was a circle
of things oh no this is a dead end
oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no let me out
maybe this is the exit where I gotta go
ah go back to the morgue then I come
through the morgue to the furnace and
that I can get the power to the furnace
until I get out of here I haven't even
seen Slendy he should friend they're too
dark to see God I think he intentionally
painted the texture of the floor blacks
I frigging class I wouldn't work on it
okay here's the door go away suck ten
[ __ ] and then go away suck out bag of
dicks a whole bag of them oh wait this
is another damn door oh no
dead end oh no oh no don't kill feet bro
don't kill me bro I'm so close to
winning I'm gonna win maybe not okay
that's this looks like okay what's down
here please don't tell me it's a dead
end
cuz I will stab you in the groin if it's
a dead end it's so down dark
so down dark okay I don't know what's
going on I seem to be like lost in
circles and nothing is helping me so
let's try going out again here and then
going across to here cuz I don't think
I've been in here I don't know what that
other way was but Sir all that's been
[ __ ] a beauty pie I think that was
written in blood
come on I'm so close oh it's gotta be in
there it's gotta be in here this is the
only other place that I haven't been
it's got to be in here right right
wrong wrong it's not here it's not here
it's not here it's not here no thank you
it's gotta be in here this is the last
no no oh I'm so screwed I don't know
where the last one is I'm spitting
everywhere that's not helping my
situation oh come on this is a sad day
that fudge don't kill me bro it's gotta
be fudge I it's gotta be somewhere here
it's gotta be somewhere here it's gotta
be
what's up here what is up here where is
this lead is this just all one big
circle or what one big circle jerk pass
okay wait what oh I didn't know there
was branching hallways here that would
have helped me okay so I went down that
way I think I went down the other one
when it came out of the the furnace area
so this way must lead to somewhere else
that can help me maybe or maze this one
oh this is the one I came in fudge
it's gotta be to the left area what's in
here
same place what's behind here nothing
god I'm really like I think I think
there might need to be ah what was that
what was that I can't run can't run okay
what's at the end of this hallway
besides like another door okay is there
just I went already went there so it's
got to be in here somewhere
teddy bear I don't know it's gotta be in
here it's gotta be gotta be gotta be
gotta be it's gotta be in here
it's his blood-covered these things
these are like beds from I think from
dead space I'm not sure oh this I've
been here I've looked here it's not here
unless it's headin like way in the
corner this back it was I could have
gotten that a long time ago where the
hell do I escape the ship go now oh I
could have gotten that so long ago where
do I go to escape the ship I do not know
I do not know I do not know I'm gonna
win finally son I'm gonna hide in here
so I can lose him in here all this is a
bad idea there's bad of is it dumb dumb
dumb dumb dumb dumb dumb dumb dumb dumb
idea where is he where is he where is he
hey Raj I need to like maybe the exits
like down this way I don't know go go
Sonny
go how do I escape you how do I escape
the shop yeah
how do I get out of here how do I win
how do I win I don't know
he's got a table at I go back in the way
I came new Oh balls
Oh Falls I think I just got a loop back
around and then go back down that
hallway that of a [ __ ] okay going
around the other way not going that way
I can win this I know I can I'm not
gonna lose it right at the end I'm not
I'm not I'm not I'm not I'm not I'm not
I'm not gonna lose it
man that sounds like change whichever
room I'm in okay just calmly relax and
get down that hallway yes
clear so far yes I see it it's all red I
knew I was supposed to go that way
I can't run why the hell can't even
Isaac Clark could sprint duh
does it clogged channeling in her bad
ass until I make it to the exit go damn
it go go go don't even think about
looking backwards I'm gonna make it
yeah again
I like it when I win I like you what I
actually can do these games
ah I'm at it I'm so amazing I'm awesome
oh well this game is still technically
in testing and beta so yeah thank you
Rick Mirae thank you for including me in
the game most prominently I I was hoping
there was he got me mashing in there I
didn't see one but maybe later on well
excuse me maybe later on they'll there
will be one so thank you all so much for
watching and thank you for suggesting it
and thank you yeah bad for letting me
steal it and thank you everybody and
thank you game creator and thank you yes
script um it's got it needs a little bit
of work but so far I really liked it
cuz I love dead space and I love slender
so the two kind of mixed together to
make it all better whole so thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation videos I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]